okay so when it comes to spider-man
films car scenes actually play a big
part in developing and defining what
peter parker stands for whether it's
lashing out to uncle ben in their last
real conversation before his death
seeing his ghost as he quits being
spider-man or coming home with tony from
his first real mission peter speaking to
an elderly mentor figure in a car is
something that has appeared at several
points throughout multiple marvel movies
i think this is often used as a framing
device because we're so used to seeing
peter swinging through the air with ease
as he glides across the city bringing
him into a confined space with little to
no room somewhat encloses the character
and means that he has to face things
head on being unable to run away or
escape means that it's in these moments
that we see what peter is truly going
through and nowhere is this shown more
than in the one during homecoming for
the last week now i've been racking my
brain to think about what my favorite
spider-man scene is i think that this
comes out on top for a number of reasons
it actually shows the difference between
peter and his villains and it works on a
lot of levels now we will be going
through it all and if you agree that
this scene is amazing then i'd massively
appreciate the thumbs up and also don't
forget to subscribe as we do videos like
this each and every week in which we
break down why a movie scene is perfect
if this is your first time here i'm your
host paul aka your friendly neighborhood
spoiler man now let's get into
spider-man homecoming
okay so the movie as a whole actually
has a lot of metaphors for the
working-class struggle we open with
adrian toombs scavenging for parts in
the wake of the battle of new york one
of the things i've always appreciated is
that tombs is a scavenger and he ends up
taking on this mantle in animal form
when he becomes the vulture this opening
should be his ticket out of poverty but
instead the fortune he would be facing
is overtaken by damage control headed up
by tony stark to tombs stark caused
destruction and now he's profiting from
it further shafting the little guy and
adding to his billions whilst adrian has
to live on the breadline there's an
amazing shot where we see stark tower
looming over central station and we pass
from that to tombs and his crew to see
them digging in the dirt on a symbolic
level it shows how stalk and people like
him tower above everything else whilst
the rest of us have to put our hands in
the mud to pick up their scraps the
introduction certainly tells us why
adrian is doing all this when he shows
us a drawing that his daughter is made
and though we don't know the pair are
related at this point it's easy to see
why he turns to a life of crime peter
later asks how he could do this still is
and tomb says that he's not doing it to
her he's doing it for her just before we
go to the title sequence tombs arrives
at his headquarters and says business is
good this is a very important line and
this intro basically has its own
self-contained arc in which we see a
supervillain origin for a working-class
man who was beaten by the elite turning
the situation on its side so that he can
win too it's important to bear in mind
not only for the car scene but also
peter's character too peter much like
tombs was only given things to do when
the elite needed him the airport scene
in civil war would have gone a lot worse
had he not been there but as soon as
that was over and stark no longer wanted
his help he was cast out to do things on
his own the majority of the first hour
of homecoming very much is peter
attempting to reach out to him and happy
but because they don't need him for
anything he's ghosted and told to stop
bothering them like tombs he's put in a
position where he has to do things on
his own because sticking to what they
say will simply have him stuck at being
the bottom rung of the ladder now peter
is idealistic and he desperately wants
to be an avenger therefore he attempts
to stop tombs whenever he can and a big
gut punch in the film comes when we
realize that he's actually the father of
liz aka peter's love interest there's a
couple of clues towards this in the
movie and for me it's up there with the
hydra twist in terms of how
unpredictable it was it leads to one of
the most tense scenes in the film in
which tombs figures out that peter
parker is spider-man
you guys hang out with spider-man
really
spider-man
wow
what's he like nice man
i've seen you around right baby i mean
somewhere we've uh have we ever because
of even the boys um he does accident to
kathleen with me
oh and it's at my party he disappeared
no no i did not disappear yes you did
you disappeared like you always do like
you did in dc too
that's terrible what happened down there
in dc though
were you
scared i bet you're glad and your old
pal spider-man showed up in the elevator
though
yo i i actually didn't go up i saw it
off on the ground
yeah very lucky that he was there that
day
good old spider-man
now this works for a number of reasons
tombs clearly recognizes peter but he
doesn't know where from he however
begins to piece it all together when
peter's absences become more and more
frequent he's left realizing that peter
parker is spider-man and john watts does
a brilliant turn with the lighting here
that shows exactly when the penny drops
tombs is that waiting at the red light
with it beaming across his face and then
this turns to green when adrian realizes
what's going on
good home spider-man
from here liz is dropped off and tomb
sits in the car with peter and he gives
him an ultimatum
nothing
more important than family you saved my
daughter's life
and i could never forget something like
that so i'm going to give you one chance
are you ready
you walk through those doors you forget
any of this happened
and don't you ever
ever
interfere with my business again
because if you do
i'll kill you
and everybody you love
hey
you just live your life
know what you say
thank you
you're welcome
now i'm gonna be completely honest with
you yeah there's been a couple of times
where i've watched this and i've
genuinely thought that if i was in that
position that i probably would have made
a partnership with tombs and we both
could have got rich together if i'd been
a high schooler yeah probably would have
just kept going out with liz made a
little business with her dad and sat
chilling ignoring the fact that my
spoiler sense was tingling i guess it's
lucky that i got bitten by a radioactive
attention seeker and decided to become a
youtuber as i would have sucked in this
role however peter and tombs are very
much parallels of one another and this
is why the latter gives the former a
choice tombs was in peter's position
once and he sees him as a naive teenager
who is simply trying to make their own
way in the world much like how he was in
fact when peter confronts tombs later on
he very much lays it out that people
like him are nothing to the elite peter
says that tomb selling weapons to people
is wrong and adrian reiterates the point
that that is exactly how stark made his
fortune he says that people like them
have to fight their wars and pick up
their scraps and because of this they
don't matter he is very much warning
peter of what will happen if he doesn't
get wise to the program and it's a very
chilling line juxtaposing this peter
sees tombs as his own future and what
will happen if he refuses to do the
right thing he's very much looking at
the older man that he could become if he
turns against what's true and though
tombs is living the high life it's truly
doomed to all come crashing down if
people like him stand up against it
tombs threatens to kill him and his
family if he interferes with his
business again and this clearly shakes
peter to the core most would walk away
and go to the dance and though it
initially seems like this is what peter
is going to do he still decides to take
tombs down even though it could have
massive repercussions due to his
identity being out there that's what
true heroes do and it's a defining
moment for the character that almost
kills him but in the end he becomes
stronger because of it now i know tony
often overshadows peter on the mcu but
this moment is very much a learning
experience for him too he very much
realizes that the people he's overlooked
are important and he ends up inviting
peter upstate because of the actions he
takes here however who this is most
important for is peter a person who up
until this point has been cast to the
side by the elite but because of his
moral fiber he hasn't taken a darker
path tombs did because he was weaker and
he ended up becoming the villain of the
story whereas peter who is given a
similar choice ends up becoming the hero
this is where the stakes are arguably
the highest for the character and even
though a big threat now knows his
identity he still puts his own needs to
the side in order to stop him it truly
is a defining moment for the character
and the way that the scene plays out is
absolutely perfect because we know that
peter could have easily lost and yet he
still charged ahead this is a spider-man
without his tech or allies taking
someone down because it's the right
thing to do it really defines not only
the character of the vulture but also
peter himself and why with great power
comes great responsibility peter could
easily use his gifts for his own
benefits but instead he applies them in
a way that will help the greater good
and because of this i think it's the
perfect spider-man scene it's one of my
favorite moments not only in the mcu but
in spider-man films in general and it's
something that i constantly go back to
as one of the best moments in well a
comic book movie ever
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the scene so make sure you
comment below and let me know if you
think there's a better one with
spider-man that speaks more to you then
i'd love to hear it and as a thank you
for interacting with the video you'll be
put into a prize draw we are giving away
three mc box sets on the 30th of august
and all you have to do to be with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the moment we picked them at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter at heavyspoilers if you
want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
spiderman no way home trailer which will
be linked on screen right now we pointed
out all the easter eggs we could find
and also discussed how they call back to
the comics so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
without the way thank you for sending
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care peace